on July 4th during this intense period a
Palestinian rammed a car into
pedestrians at a bus stop in Tel Aviv
injuring eight people before being shot
dead by a passerby
also that night Hamas fired rock is into
Israel and then Israel responded with
strikes on what it said was an
underground weapon site
so just to give some context to the
intensives
violence happening here what do you
think about Hamas firing Rockets into
Israel
well it's the framing makes it seem as
though like
unprovoked Hamas is like firing Rockets
unto Israel regardless of what I think
of Hamas obviously but unprovoked but
that's not the case the propagation is
the fact that they are forced to live in
a cage
that they have no access to clean water
they have no access to basic rights no
access to uh Imports no access to
anything
that they can't leave their living in a
densely populated
Enclave that was deemed uninhabitable by
the U.N that was deemed an open air
prison
um so the rockets in any case are
retaliation for the seeds let's start
there but again this is just to prove my
point violence begets violence
Palestinian people are not violent
people we are not violent people at the
core and I think you know what serves
this narrative is islamophobia is like
xenophobia towards Arabs which we don't
have like I don't have the luxury you
know to like to write laws about
um by the way I'm I'm quite I'm quite
you know frustrated by this uh I am I am
preoccupied and the Palestinian people
are preoccupied
um with the material violence that we
have to deal with on the day-to-day the
demolitions the bombings uh the
imprisonment that's what we're
distracted with and and busy with that
we can't even talk about the racism
um The Casual racism against the
anti-palestinal racism being in the
media on social media and diplomatic
circles and but all of this all of this
racism that has gone unchecked has not
been regulated
um for decades allows for these tropes
to continue in which Palestinians are
promoted as these like barbaric
terrorists and the only way we could
remedy uh that situation is to is by
marketing them as these like defenseless
victims but the fact of the matter is
isn't is not this simplistic Palestinian
people are human beings who should enjoy
a full spectrum of humanity which in
includes raids which includes this day
which includes happiness and joy and
laughter which includes celebration
which includes
um all of these things but we're not
allowed this but we are doing exactly
what any people throughout history who
have been oppressed who have been
colonized who have been occupied have
done and continue to do as we see in
Ukraine which is celebrated by
mainstream media I'm sorry to uh keep
reiterating this point but
you know at this point uh
I am quite you know
exhausted by how exceptional Palestine
and Palestinian resistance is when the
world tells me time and time again that
it doesn't have a problem with violence
it just has a problem with who does that
violence
do you in your mind and in the way you
see this region uh draw a distinction
between the people in power versus the
regular people so you mentioned the
Palestinian people
is there something you can comment on on
Hamas and the PLO
uh do you see them as fundamentally
different
from the people
uh what does Hamas do well where did
they fall short
I think governments uh wherever globally
any are different from people no
government is a true reflection of its
people I think uh
you know this is even true in the case
of like Arab countries that normalize
with Israel in many of the cases there
are um unelected governments
I think the Palestinian Authority
continues to fail I think there are
subcontractors the Israeli regime
through their security coordination
and also I'd like to use this as an
opportunity to comment a little bit on
the
on the analogy thing not to like
stray away from the question but you
know
um the Palestinian Authority
two years ago killed an opposition
activist named nizorbanat
it was a horrendous crime and I was in
Ramallah
with the people protesting against the
Palestinian Authority and at some point
they had their batons the Palestinian
Authority police and they beat us with
it and many of the people on the crowd
were liking the Palestinian Authority to
Zionism
I think people this is what people do
we when they are confronted by a great
evil they liken it to some other great
evil and this is where the Hitler
analogy came from
um again I don't think it's like the
best strategy moving forward but I
refuse you know to be
uh
uh you know criminalized for a little
sentence
but to linger on those in power so one
of the criticisms towards Hamas and PLO
towards the Israeli government
at least the current coalition
government
is um
that there's a lot of incentive to sort
of perpetuate violence to maintain power
there's a hunger for power and and
maintaining that power amongst the
powerful that's the way power works so
is there a worry you have about
those in power not having the best
interests of its people so those empower
the PLO Hamas not
uh not being incentivized towards peace
towards Justice
you know looking at the PA's action
today it tells you a great deal about
what they're interested in and what
they're not interested in and maybe yeah
the occupation is in their best interest
um and you can infer similar things
looking at at Hamas but the two the two
these two entities virtually have no
power even Hamas
um Yani there is you know the the
context that Hamas is permitted through
by international law uh to use armed
resistance blah blah blah does that mean
Hamas is like equipped to govern Jose I
don't think so does that mean that uh
people around Palestine necessarily want
to want to live under uh
Hamas rule in 2006 Hamas was
democratically elected I don't know if
that's still the case today
um there is there's a lot to be said but
neither of these entities have any real
power
um in in perpetuating they don't the the
only the only body that has access that
can flip the switch and all of this
equation
is Israelis you know they're the ones
who are keeping people in a case they're
the ones who are
um wrapping the West Bank with a with a
wall
um everything else to me is just
secondary regardless of what I think
personally of any of those people I know
personally for me I I the world I
Envision not just Palestine the world I
Envision is a world that goes beyond
States
um that goes beyond this uh uh framing
of power this this hierarchy in which uh
some people will over other people this
whole idea of nation-states be it Israel
or any other nation states it's
it's
futile it's not good it's exclusive I
think that we can achieve a better world
than that
well the you know how do you do a better
world they actually if you just Linger
on that like what
what
the politically speaking geopolitically
you have to have representation of the
people you have to have
laws you have to have leaders in
governing bodies that enact those laws
and all those kinds of things you
probably need to have militaries to
protect the people can you not imagine a
world without militaries
I can imagine it but we're not in that
world
yeah I'm not saying you know I have all
the answers of our PowerPoint in my
pocket you know with the instructions
but I I'm saying the world I'd like to
live in is one that transcends borders
is one
that you know does not necessitate
militaries that doesn't necessitate all
of these
um prisons of these walls all of these
racist laws so you don't think violence
is a fundamental part of human nature
that emerges
and like combined with the hunger for
power
I do think I do think that both of these
things are like truly intrinsic to to
human beings but I also do think there
is a way to move Beyond them I'm not
saying I have the answers
um I'm tempted Safeway but
but you have a hope that there doesn't
have to be War yeah yeah in the world
definitely definitely